you've got a feel for variables versus
constants predicates versus subjects the
quantifiers know some and all and taking
advantage of valid variables and their
scope to translate everyday phrases into
logic if that's not true please go back
and watch the last three videos in this
series it's time to move on to logical
operators or connectives logical
connectives let's build our sentences
out a bit more to do that let's start
with the logical connectives and and or
we can join two symbols with and the
conjunction can come between two
statements like she saw Bob and the
house is red or this is a fish and fish
can swim the conjunction might come
between two variables like x and y but
and has less obvious applications if we
want to say that Bob is a good person we
can break that sentence into Bob is
human and Bob is good we can render some
good person as for some X X is human and
X is good like many operators and may be
represented by different symbols in
different texts for now stick with one
and learn others as needed
also let me mention that the meaning of
this logical ant is pretty strong it
asserts both things being joined so it's
vanilla and chocolate means that it's
both vanilla and chocolate it's not the
week and of you can choose between
vanilla and chocolate where you actually
mean or speaking of or we can join
sentences with or as well this
disjunction might come between two
statements like P or Q like this is
vanilla or this is chocolate but we can
also use it with variables X or Y so
everything is vanilla or chocolate means
that all X's are vanilla chocolate or
both both yes this or is called
inclusive so when you're joining two
things with the logical or realize that
you're saying the first thing the second
thing or both of them if you want to
rule out the option of both of them you
have to use what's called an exclusive
or it's vanilla
it's chocolate but it's not chocolate +
vanilla these aunts and ORS bring up a
topic I brought up before the scope of a
quantifier look at what happens when two
predicates are in a quantifier scope it
applies to both of them for all X X is
human and X can swim just means
everybody can swim for some X X is dirty
or X is cluttered something is dirty or
cluttered where you're saying that this
thing may be dirty cluttered or both
dirty and cluttered last for some X X is
not dirty or X is not cluttered with an
exclusive or
what happens when you negate two symbols
joined by and or or like not chocolate
or vanilla a set of rules known as the
de Morgan's laws will help you deal with
those cases if you want to say not
chocolate and vanilla you'll represent
the phrases not chocolate or vanilla on
the flip side you when you want to say
not chocolate or vanilla this comes out
as not vanilla and chocolate in logic
not chocolate or vanilla is treated the
same as not chocolate and not vanilla
well not chocolate and vanilla is
treated like not chocolate or not
vanilla before moving on to the rest of
the connectives here are a few phrases
to translate use and or or that's either
and or or for each statement
on to some new stuff you're probably
already familiar with the equals symbol
as you'd expect this indicates a logical
equivalence like some X is equal to some
Y nothing new here so let's move on
consider sentences where you say that if
one thing is true then something else
follows this if-then construction is
very important in logic will use it to
structure even very basic statements
where it's hidden in ordinary language
let's take the statement English is a
language no if-then there the logic for
this simple sentence is actually for all
X if X is English then X is a language
we can translate it this way where the
horseshoe symbol is the if-then
conditional take another sentence this
time everybody swims in logic that's for
all X if X is human then X swims there
are other popular symbols for this
conditional like the left-to-right arrow
like the versions of an x' and nots
there are different ways of writing the
same symbol the logic is the same
there's another type of conditional
called the by conditional the meaning
here is quite different it's if and only
if let's take the sentence only water is
refreshing the sentence means for all X
X is refreshing if and only if X is
water
ratchet this up one level it's only
edible if it's good food here we mean
for all X X is edible if and only act if
X is good and X is food
notice that this if and only if is
really strong what's refreshing has to
be water and what's water has to be
refreshing
likewise what's good food has to be
edible and what's edible has to be good
food next one when you're drawing a
conclusion in language you often use the
word therefore this therefore indicates
that whatever follows is implied by
whatever came before you can show this
in logic with a triple dot before your
conclusion let's say you propose a
simple line of reasoning like everybody
knows something
John somebody so he knows something
you're probably getting used to
translations into logic by now so I'll
let you figure those phrases out the
first one that's right for all X for
some Y if X is human
the next knows why that's everybody
knows something your next line is simple
John is human and the last therefore for
some Y Joe John knows why that's just
about all the basic stuff you need to
begin uncovering the logic behind
everyday language of course there are
other logics that expand the use of
formal logic and give it a variety of
applications let's take a look at one
basic example of such a logic called
modal logic modal logic allows you to
incorporate modal's into the formal
structure I briefly explored modal verbs
in the lessons on morphology or the
grammar of words and language examples
of modal verbs in English are can may
and must the basic modal symbols in
modal logic are it is necessary and it
is possible for example think of a
statement P take this as dogs read books
if we say that it is necessary that P
this means it is necessary that dogs
read books we can also say that dogs can
read books it is not necessary that
everyone read books and dogs cannot read
books notice that when we say something
like kin or it is possible that leaves a
lot of room to discuss the probability
of that
ability which is one of those topics
I'll tackle in the next video I know
I've said a lot out at you but I'm
fairly sure you are already getting a
feel for how this kind of logic really
gets down to the structure of thoughts
expressed in language so let's move on
to do a few translations pause the video
whenever you need some time to think
that was fun wasn't it well wrapped up
these lessons next time with the
discussion of how to represent members
of a set and expressed the language of
probability and logic until next time
keep practicing